welcoming James it's been a long time  finally here we  Sandman has just made a beautiful movie  and I'm very proud of it  my best experience watching this movie  was at the IMAX in London it was when I  felt most proud of it it looks  incredible it sounds incredible and just  old experience as a specialness to it  Sam really tapped into that nostalgic  classic bond Sam managed to make the  best opening of any Bond movie I've ever  seen there's a lot of action and  excitement and I think it is added value  to see it in IMAX look around you James  it's quite simply the best viewing  experience or did you come which is why  you should see it in IMAX I feel sorry  for people who don't see it in IMAX you  came here to kill me  it was made for for you guys to see it  on the big screen  it's bigger and better than any bond  I've seen cocea watts in theaters man  don't wait for DVD don't like to see it  at home it's a beautiful film man you  got to see an IMAX  you